Guess who might be looking to put on his happy
face again, bringing a little laughter and
a lot of anarchy to the mean streets of Gotham?
In the eight decades since making his appearance
in the pages of Batman #1, he's been called
everything from "The Clown Prince of Crime,
to "The Ace of Knaves," to "Puddin'."
"You know what's great about you, Puddin'?
You really put the 'fun' in 'funeral.'’
He's also been called a psychopath who "just
wants to watch the world burn."
Todd Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix are calling
him Arthur Fleck, though most of us have come
to know him simply as Joker.
By the end of director Phillips and star Phoenix's
new film, Joker, that's presumably the name
and villainous persona Arthur will take.
While the pair's anxiously anticipated film
is still weeks away from release, it's already
generating a whirlwind of mostly positive
press on the festival circuit — with many
critics praising Phoenix's turn as the titular
baddie as the best incarnation of the Joker
yet.
Some are even speculating Phoenix's performance
may well net him the Best Actor statue that's
somehow eluded the actor throughout his diverse
and ambitious career.
Understandably, that sort of praise already
has people buzzing about whether or not there's
a chance for a Joker 2, and whether or not
Phoenix would be open to reprising his role
for it.
So, will we ever see a Joker sequel?
Let's discuss.
Joker was pitched and produced as a standalone
project, so we can tell you right off the
bat that there is no immediate plan for a
Joker follow-up.
That being said, director Todd Phillips recently
went on the record with Total Film to state
he would be more than willing to make another
Joker movie if Phoenix were on board for the
project — and he certainly makes it sound
like Phoenix might be considering the possibility.
He told Total Film:
"One thing I will tell you: I would do anything
with Joaquin, any day of the week.
There's nobody like him.
If he was willing to do it, and if people
show up to this movie, and Warners came to
us and said, 'You know what?
If you guys could think of something…'
Well, I have a feeling that he and I could
think of something pretty cool."
There's a lot to unpack in that quote, so
before we get too ahead of ourselves, we can
tell you that Phoenix himself has neither
confirmed nor denied his interest in appearing
in a Joker sequel — but what's interesting
about Phillips' statement is how clear it
is that both he and Phoenix had a ton of fun
bringing their version of Joker to life.
Furthermore, if one were inclined toward a
bit of conjecture, you could also take Phillips'
comment as a hint that the two have already
thought of where they'd take the story, and
are just waiting to see how Joker plays with
audiences before pursuing the next step.
"'How's your job?
Are you having any negative thoughts?'
All I have are negative thoughts."
For Phillips' part, he's seemingly already
brought a game-changing concept to the fray
for this first Joker.
As has been well covered in the press, this
incarnation of the Joker is a version of the
character that has nothing to do with any
Joker that's appeared before.
Free from the shackles of comic book lore,
TV, and cinematic canon, Phillips and Phoenix
set out to make the most of their blank slate
and craft a version of Joker the likes of
which have never been seen before.
As for whether or not Phoenix will return
for a Joker sequel, we'll just have to wait
and see.
Robert Pattinson certainly stoked the fires
of rumor-ville by inadvertently alluding to
a possible cameo of Phoenix's Joker in his
upcoming The Batman, but Phoenix has been
quite vocal about the emotional toll the role
took on him.
He told reporters during a Venice Film Festival
presser that while playing Joker, you, quote,
"start to go a little mad."
Even if the studio wants a sequel, the idea
that Phoenix would return to the role doesn't
seem guaranteed.
While it may be a challenge for Phoenix to
step back into the makeup for Joker 2, Phillips'
remarks also imply that Joker's box office
take and critical reception may well influence
whether or not it happens.
Critics are already being very kind to the
film — but the rest, as it seems, is up
to the moviegoing public.
If you want to see Phoenix and Phillips return
for Joker 2, make sure you show Joker a little
love when the film finally arrives in theaters
on October 4.
"When you bring me out… could you introduce
me as 'Joker?'"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.